welcome back to Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts rich Voss is here you can call
the show at eight six six nine six nine
one nine six nine you can also follow us
this is why it's good to have all forms
of social media
Twitter's in and out some I guess some
hacker group came in d-bag told me
during the break some it must be the
Russians I would blame Putin again but
they seem to have taken down Twitter
reddit and Spotify see oh the future is
the Internet
hackers can't take down satellites can
they those son of a [ __ ] will still
be here if you get that Google pixel
phone yeah you won't be able to listen
your music got Spotify yeah I got Apple
music I can listen whatever I want right
now yeah you're right because Apple
music would be impossible to hack and
you feel stupid though no I had totally
stupid right because they'd be at
Spotify this time so obviously every
time it would be Spotify right I see I
see no you're right you're right I went
to the cellphone store yesterday to look
at it say what it's called once the car
the Verizon store do anything drop a
name-brand the cellphone store I went it
at a cell phone store and they didn't
have them in stock they'd like the 32
also see what they're doing with the
Google pixel phones is their quote
unquote exclusively from Verizon but all
you have to do is put in a SIM card you
know what I mean they're unlocked so
well you would have to buy it outright
right so I was like well can I just buy
a phone from you how much I want to know
how much it was and they said no the
only way you can buy a phone outright
from the Verizon store is you have to
buy it on prepaid with a $45 prepaid
card and then once you're done with that
then it would be unlock you do whatever
you want so it's an extra $90 because
it's an activation fee and then a
prepaid that now when they say it's
exclusive to Verizon is that because
nobody else wanted it no no it's a it's
a deal that they made that's bad deal
hey let's get on as few networks boss
they got a great deal you can also buy
it on the on the Google store where's
that it's on the computer how yeah I
don't know the hackers might have gotten
but uh I'm still I might get it this
weekend
I want it fine one first well yeah I
guess because they're at the they go uh
the Verizon store today's launch day or
yesterday was launch day and they're
like yeah well haven't been stock and I
went and they're like yeah we got him in
stock which one do you want black or
white and it's like I guess black and
they were like okay 32 gigs it was like
what no 32 gigs 128 gigs nobody need 32
gigs on a phone I guess you could also
go to like Best Buy and stuff because
they sell every carriers stuff now you
can I get one too I don't only get them
in the Verizon store Evan there's no
line no there's no lines they didn't
even get them in they don't want they
only got 32 gigs you can't get 128 gig
version yes enough gigs so who's doing
this go go this is where all these
[ __ ] stupid go wrong you dopes yeah
and then they made a blue one and it's
limited edition they don't have the blue
one on launch day it's already you're
spoken for somehow this is the Wurster
they're trying to be Apple and create a
buzz yeah it's like now that people you
know we're to us know now that people
are so annoyed with the new iPhone this
was your chance and you don't have the
[ __ ] high gig models what dopes
that's what they call I went in I was
like where's the high gig model they
didn't have them no 128 K that was their
reasoning beside the fact that we're
[ __ ] what was their reasoning there
like we see them in the warehouse but we
didn't get them in we need so we should
have them maybe this weekend or by next
week a while away the [ __ ] type of asset
you know what if they want to sell the
low gig ones first yeah and get rid of
them although like people who are
excited about a new gadget you're gonna
go in and get these 32 gig Google pixel
phones and and then and be left with
nothing
see they're thinking share an SD card
slot no oh really
no there is no it's gonna say maybe
that's why their deal with this phone
that they're trying to sell people on is
anybody who gets it gets unlimited video
and photo storage online so you don't
need more gigs right wait like Jim
Norton wouldn't use that because you
know what that means what you have to
use the cloud not happening not
happening now not not to send you think
people have all your information hack
you if they can hack you it's true yeah
absolutely true I don't know I like 32
gazes nothing on a phone is a [ __ ] but
if you're streaming music and your
are storing everything in the [ __ ]
Google whatever because they said hi
even HD videos at whatever you want
unlimited storage you could store it
online you don't need to store it on
your but it's not even 32 gigs because
you know you've got to think about how
much space like just the the phone's
operating system is taking out and all
the apps that come with it and whatever
apps you get yeah you so you store it
you can just stream it yeah but that's
not a Wi-Fi connection but it's [ __ ]
it's right the text message I mean watch
[ __ ] I mean watch a pocke lipped on
my phone plus I'm sure like if you feel
if you're filming an HD video it's not
like automatically saving to the cloud
like it's got to you know record
somewhere right right so you need the
memory to actually record the video you
can't just have zero memory engage be a
cloud phone yeah what's it gonna be
called the the old goldfish with you
knows your memory Oh
cares live google sky um don't they call
it no it's pixel it's called the pic so
I hate technology I'm so bad at it I'm
trying to send some of my mailing list
of course I'm doing it wrong I really
about worthless pieces you don't need a
mail you know if you don't have to send
anything your mailing list to be that
well that was really worthy that was
good I was really worried yeah were you
gonna ask like the iPhone 6 plus I hate
the iPhone why because I have the iPhone
6 plus I updated it it made my phone a
piece of [ __ ] and now I feel like I'm
being held hostage by these iPhones
because I didn't even want an iPhone 7
there's nothing new about it except the
camera and the processor is fast enough
that it can actually use the operating
system that they created so I like
there's nothing about it that makes me
want it but they've trapped me into this
cycle where it's like okay it's time for
a new phone you better get this when you
back at this when you better get this
one I feel like I need a change I need
to disrupt the awful cycle I need to let
Eddy Cue and the boys know that they got
to make some improvements that make me
go oh wow
there's no oh wow factors no they don't
care and they don't care if you stopped
using the iPhone any more than they care
like I was talking to somebody recently
about banks and he's like Bank of
America and I hate banker burger and he
goes yeah I stopped putting my money in
the bank
Oh tests and I get that because I've
thought of that but of course you can't
do it because they're just annoying but
see they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
care they don't care if you don't use
the iPhone they don't care if I take my
money out of the bank because there's so
many people there so big that's not the
way to protest too big to fail they
don't give a [ __ ] no the too big to be
noticed if you don't yeah but if enough
people do like it there's no way to get
all those people to do that yes care
what's that I think banks care at least
they did a few years ago when I when I
closed one of my accounts because you
can get better interest rates online so
I do think that they care because
they'll try to keep you uh maybe because
you can get if you if you put your money
in you know one of the there's a lot of
different like online an online bank yes
[ __ ] wants to do that online because
it's it's for its for people who can
afford to put their money in there
because you get higher interest rates
because there's no brick-and-mortar
banks so they can afford to give a lot
of people do on where's your money your
money it's in the cloud Jim well while
your money's at her house and his house
I would not do that it's a wonderful why
they're all like they're all FDIC
insured it's not like online banking is
that you're giving your money to me like
I I don't I don't want to be the one to
say this but on you being like why would
anybody use online banking is like voss
being like oh I just heard about this
e-zpass thing like every night you up to
the bank I don't know I thank online but
with a bank like with Bank of America
Wells Fargo at least you can go in there
and take money out if you want to you
can still do that I'll beg on my if you
want to transfer money from one account
to another account cool you know it was
a good day with you rich you are
agreeing with Jim yeah and he had to be
mean didn't he I don't care that she's
it's his you know what it is he's trying
to start down and build himself up
because she's dealing with whatever he's
dealing with but that's my deal I'm
content where I am in life you are and
yeah I am good for you so uh I'm really
not you know so he could do what he has
to do to make him feel good and I'm here
for him no matter what he does
that's a see that's what people need in
life a good friend like respond if you
know look whatever he's going through if
he wants to try to beat me up hey I'm
there for you
what do you need what do you want to
talk about you know I'm Jeff I'm John
that's right I hope your headphones I'm
sorry I need to turn to a guy that
looked like him if I can't start by a
Hornet here we go nice professional met
Sara just walked in trying to figure out
why he walked into a a gentler warmer
studio boss talking about his friendship
goals sim nice to meet you man and you
two met Sara and this is it and you
might say au revoir of course I'm yeah
Wow is you not her to me
Oh how's it going I can't complain I
just got off the train
well you're like I stopped at Midtown
comics I had some time to kill took a
smash I ruined the bathroom would you
just
I was yeah I you saw it I thought I know
yeah I saw somebody peeking through a
[ __ ] stall like a creep like my buddy
Jimmy were you just in there yeah we
just walked in there yeah heard you talk
about something you're not doing no more
in this I'm gonna talk about it now but
yeah I was in the store I want to yell
at your name but are you sure we'll be
the first time ever you know it's
habitual would you take your training
front we're from Long Island no no in
New York isn't a New York like what the
[ __ ] does that mean yeah of course it's
Long Island New York I'm a high top I'd
espresso like I had a rough night's
sleep because my kids woke up I have
three little girls and it was like every
hour my wife even said she this is every
hour on the hour
how old are the kids seven five and
three so they're not like babies that
should be waking up everybody say you're
okay gagging in there this spitting up
[ __ ] I don't know man it's it's rough I
don't sweat it
yqc wait till they get older how old are
your kids 27 no 26 24 and 9
oh you spread them out a little bit well
different wife but oh there you go yeah
he said 26 year old is dating
I don't just none in the studio talented
broadcaster oh is that right oh she's
he's a good guy and she your oldest is
dating somebody you know no I'm proud of
all my kids and who all their choices in
life
I really am yes like Tony Soprano
described like
charcoal briquette wood metal bring some
fur that's funny though there are
watching clips of [ __ ] Sopranos this
I watch we [ __ ] on YouTube and this
morning for some reason is watching
clips on YouTube of [ __ ] Sopranos has
nothing well you brought Sopranos right
thinking of it I find one that Jim got
clipped yeah and I was watching when
they ripped off the UM the [ __ ] poker
game yeah they shot Furio and shadow leg
again same shades play hated Furio did
you I hated that whole lot already ours
but that whole like romantic thing yeah
oh and he does his garage work he's all
sweaty dude I got it women like Furio
though oh yeah when I'm on the screen my
wife because she didn't watch Sopranos
when it was on so I got to like rewatch
it with her and I showed it to her and
everything this was a couple years ago
and we were walking down the street and
we saw Furio and he looks like fear yo
you still get the ponytail and
everything and she like almost left a
puddle in the sidewalk she was so
excited about this guy he's a director
he's a real director my buddy ray Longo
was just in a movie of his called the
Brooklyn banker and really I saw that
one was here the guy furious yeah I did
a little skit with him that we put on
Twitter to promote it and we shot it a
trail on goes uh and Chris Weidman gym
in Long Island and just to promote it
about the [ __ ] thing way I could find
that thing I was I was called thank
y'all you guys are good I wish for me
some club soda for the people at home
with me I was camping in Pennsylvania
and the guy the Russian was still
running through the woods in the Pine
Barrens whatever happened to him a
surprise you know I'll tell you
I interviewed David Chase few years back
and I asked him like what happened to
the Pine Barrens guy and he said he had
a whole story in his head about what
happened to him he said he kept running
he passed out somewhere some Boy Scouts
found him but none of it was ever
actually on the show he just had this
whole thing worked out Furio I'm glad
that he came up because you didn't like
him at all or just a romantic storyline
Jim I didn't like the romantic storyline
I did not a tough guy or as a killer I
didn't like the romantic storyline with
him and the wife but then again I like
when she wanted to [ __ ] the guy worked
at Home Depot
yeah yeah right what you wanted to bang
the priest yeah there's a lot you know
what the problem with with Carmela was
it was such a morning she's probably she
probably the best pure actor in the
entire series oh it was the fact though
that it became a little soap opera ish
they had to stretch it out they had to
give all these characters life I what do
you do with her like there was some
storyline she had that I thought were
amazing she's [ __ ] with trying to
flip a house and she's mad at her father
she wants her husband to use his mob
influence to get these [ __ ]
inspectors to pass the would like there
was a lot of [ __ ] that I thought was
very like it seemed like realistic like
that you deal with one of my favorite
lines on the whole show was a Furio line
when they're like when the doctor won't
won't answer
uncle juniors calls because he's being
too difficult and they intimidate him on
the golf course and they back him up and
they back him up until he's standing in
a puddle and Furio knocks his hat off
and goes you got a B on your head oh
yeah thank God sing himself golf is
tough enough yeah make the golf it's so
tough yeah to do that to somebody in
such a tough game yeah it's mean was it
you're a golfer yes and it's killing me
you gotta be on the UI it's my favorite
dr. Kennedy not he'd not care for dr.
Kennedy I tell you the dr. Kennedy
straightened up he called uncle Jun
right away right away I think this guy
was going to say something about me
playing golf I think he thinks it's a
[ __ ] scam at telling Oh golf yeah I
only do miniature I don't [ __ ] around I
can't because she I'm a bum because ye
shitty at it huh
I probably be shitty I don't reach is
about to comment tonight no I was he
actually he was gonna really that's a
reason is it not good for stocky people
or short people
nothing miniature golf would she would
be regular golf but what I'm saying
waiting oh sorry are you are you going
home now uh nothing I got greedy [ __ ]
dick Oh run you're a killer mm a guy
though right oh yeah I'm retired now do
you know like I got a million you you
guys I don't you watch MMA watch I see
when I I stop karate and you watch the
family [ __ ] like golf you don't watch
any of that
please bye I see back in the day I used
to let love guys like Bill Wallace and
and alright you know I've been Wallace I
didn't quite eCollege with him he was a
super foot yeah yeah like his left foot
nice guy yeah very nice guy and you so
you don't do karate at all anymore
no I stopped I told you my one time I've
seen boss do karate we're in a village
okay
and he was shot I was with a girl and he
was gonna show us a move and he threw a
kick just slipped in the garbage juice I
fell in the garbage no balcony yeah you
know better back in the day he doubled
over we should be ace lifted all thy
guardianship stuff you know the big
fight with the girl impressed we had
such a land to fight in our I think it
was a thrill in Manila whatever won one
of those big fights yeah the opening
fight was a karate fight was Jeff Smith
the world champ for scream Allah who
used to have a school in Newark and Jeff
Smith was a killer killer so what I do
Rosanna like MMA it's just I don't have
time to start a new sport yeah I have
nothing sometimes if I see it on TV I'll
flip and watch it yeah it's [ __ ]
great you can do it though watching it
once a month like if you just watch the
pace right that's enough huh it's not
that big of a time commitment to just
follow it okay I'm just saying I'm on
the road so much you know I don't know
it's like no one goes to the shows you
know you're not about it yeah you know I
have I'm not negative towards you saying
you don't have the kind of free time
that Norton has no there's no I have a
life yeah I saw wants to just be like
hey MMN guys can I hang you know cuz
he's they say MMN guys in MMA guys we
should double check that out what do you
say we can go to the test box and find
out whether or not you're set MMN or MMA
yet yes did this uh did this guy just
say mmm please also I know is I would
not [ __ ] with any of them I think it's
cool I think it's [ __ ] it's very
entertaining it's the only thing I watch
I don't watch any sports anything
I don't watch anything with a [ __ ]
ball I just thought that into it and it
would sound like I'm unmanly except for
that whole think about me he's the fight
Cades on very manly yet I don't watch
sports either but I don't fight in a
cage so people think I'm a girl you know
it doesn't work as well for your radio
personality you could use Newcombe no
check that way the radio guy she look at
it like that tension do you look at him
right there yeah to me MMA doesn't have
the technique that Taekwondo or karate
or oh that's [ __ ]
Oh hundred percent well that's like
that's Piet's that's then that's what I
would call um challenge talking about
you're out of your ass I'd say okay
because you you never watching you just
flick through that's a that's like like
I don't know I explained that's like
that's like Larry King telling Jim
Norton that ah that's right it's street
fighting really Larry really gay was a
noise it dude is such beautiful
technique in MMA I could show you some
matches where you might just think of it
it's street fighting because all he's
elbowing him in the face but uh this I
mean there's so many disciplines
involved you have to be it's like people
like oh well they're not throwing
punches like boxers yeah but if you have
all the weight on that front leg
somebody's gonna kick that [ __ ] leg
off so it's it's it's really it you have
to be so skilled in not just one form of
fighting but several you got a mix man
of mixed martial artists speaking forgot
that speaking of speaking of [ __ ] we
do need to find out from the Tefft box
whether the would term MMA was used or
if it was a different term I got it you
ready yes
yeah I want to just be like hey MMN guys
man yeah mmm yeah is it ninnie it's
motion then he said I'm gonna become a
big fan of it and why you should watch
it man you might you might right you
watch it when I can in the hotel room so
when you when you retire yes like in
because you're tied in 2013 right I
suppose so I was 36 I don't have to do
the math I'm 42 now so yeah it's not
much definitely so did you you still
were you able to maintain your fandom or
did you just have to step away from it
for a little bit did I what no
maintain your fandom of it like did you
keep watching it and staying up-to-date
yeah you know I was eight interest it
was a fan
like from the beginning like I love
watching the fights
that's all that's when the big fights
come on I'm watching anyway like I enjoy
it I just I enjoy everything about it's
all like that's all I watch like I said
you like your girls oh I love the girls
yes I do yes I tell myself I have to
yeah nominal man because they're just uh
first of all that they're they're bad
they just bad asses man they know how to
fight and uh and they could beat the
[ __ ] out of most guys like average guys
on the street these girls are badass is
Amanda Nunez cat Zingano obviously Ronda
Rousey these girls know how to fight so
it's not like when girls started doing
um like I'd say either boxing or
whatever else and it eventually they
started looking okay but in the
beginning it was like oh this is [ __ ]
horrendous uh enjoy the girls boxing at
first I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
watching I mean there wasn't as much
skill it was just watch just [ __ ]
going in there throwing kind of straight
punches but just kind of Rock'em Sock'em
and they didn't pack much of a punch and
whatever I'm doing about early on when
they started getting a Thai boxing but
with the martial arts these girls know
what they they know what the hell
they're doing
these girls are tough some of the best
fights on a condo the other other
girlfriend yeah my biggest problem with
with MN P is exact that fighters are too
underpaid like a box will go out make 20
million by 15 then why Anna your biggest
probably because she's guys on she's
trying to like a thing I know he's
trying to get he is struck out with a
few technique numeration the watch no I
know I feel bad cause she's guys
watching [ __ ] fighting to the death
and you're not getting paid why don't
you get paid and I'm like MMA guys that
make a lot of money though aren't there
there is and uh and it is also a [ __ ]
young sport yeah and and not for nothing
I'm doing alright I'm I'm I'm living the
dream and I owe a lot of it through you
know just just through my fighting you
know it gave me such opportunities Conor
McGregor has very nice suits
oh yeah no comment very expensive guys
that guys [ __ ] kill yeah he's making
50 60 grand a fight yeah but I did more
than that yeah he's doing he's doing
phenom
and uh yes some guys are getting big
paid some real money and if you win
enough you do the right thing you make
the right moves or if you got a decent
personality the kid that could hurt that
could help and you could make a nice
living man and endorsements to the
endorsements are out there now right the
endorsements I mean myself I was always
I have besides being the whole fighter
thing I was a teacher first basically I
teach Brazilian jiu-jitsu I have two
schools on Long Island and I've been
I've been running my school since my
first law run since 2001 so I mean and
now my schools are both both of them
over 12,000 square feet they're
beautiful schools they run in like
clockwork
and uh you know between doing that and I
got my gig with Jimmy over on UFC
unfiltered guy that very fun gig was
that twice a week right me and Jimmy do
a a podcast two times a week and it's
called UFC unfiltered the official by
the way podcast the USU
yeah everybody the most got a [ __ ]
podcast I'm telling people like a magnum
Alma yeah I will do my podcast like oh
yeah great and I'm like that but it's
it's a real [ __ ] it's funny though right
had nobody gives a [ __ ] my kids oh [ __ ]
oh yeah you gotta tell them it's the
u.s. podcast because otherwise it's like
I was the affero just doing and if you
just doing an MMA podcast I guess what
he's doing that's fun is that in your
basement graduate sometime how many
fights you you have oh [ __ ] I don't know
all these nationals I mean you did fight
professionally I'm a professor of fights
I don't know man if I had my producer
yo-yo Christa producer look it up but I
don't [ __ ] know but you could you
could you could watch some my stuff on
UFC fight pass look at me if she loves
me I'm [ __ ] promoting everything but
what if you like us to hang out my buddy
Jimmy and meet Sam I want to meet Sam
what if you like do another podcast so
far cuz you guys the reason the podcast
is good is because it brings people into
the world like a kid I can bring em in
slowly like there are a lot of people
who are on the show that aren't fighters
you know it's not just like the inside
you missed stupid it's not just sort of
you know super super inside yeah
what if you like doing on it what all i
doing what you liked doing like what
something like I listen I never pictured
myself doing anything radio podcast type
of
I just I just never did I mean that's
you know I could talk I could talk like
a [ __ ]
but I never it's just I just never
thought about exploring that and I was
um I was this is not what you asked them
okay I'm telling you how I got into it
but Dana I was shooting a show called
Dana White looking for a fight on
YouTube
it's a it's a it's a reality show I do
with the president of the UFC Dana ye
sure sure and me him another buddy oz we
go to uh we go to all around the country
to these smaller
m-may events looking for upcoming talent
TV for the UFC or to get on The Ultimate
Fighter and while we're there we do
wacky [ __ ] it's a it's a great show so
if anybody hasn't seen it Dana White
looking for a fight and it's on YouTube
but we were doing that show and Dana
brought up to me goes look he said I
want you to do the podcast you know and
this and that
so like man I'll give it a shot and then
when he said I was gonna do with Jimmy
I've you know I've done the the old uh
the Opie and Anthony show or I met Jimmy
there and then I've seen Jimmy at events
and we always got along and I was I was
psyched about that because I like Jimmy
and now I love Jimmy ya know I feel like
I know Jimmy forever yeah Bert you know
who started the like swole up bald white
guy look cuz I feel like that I mean Jim
unreason and this is why the signal
motion was out of them I I don't know
Jim started cuz he's like he's like the
deflated version of the MMA look like
you got it
Rogen's got it Dana White's got it
everybody's like the big beefy bald
white dude yeah you know oh look at that
Dana White looking for a fight would you
get that on YouTube or fight piss also
somebody put that on the screen
I got a TD like a [ __ ] guys he's
all on the push I knows Jimmy always
want to apologize cuz when I came in I
don't Midtown comics Massapequa New York
I'm [ __ ] running all over the place
but um give me that questioning it the
swirl of bold white guy yeah you know I
mean that's just about tapping out to
the [ __ ] haircut I was up until few
years ago up until a few years ago I was
getting a money fade every week my buddy
decks the bar but was I'd go there than
a bar bits lounge and I was fun yeah fun
man I felt like in one of those Bombay
with the guys yeah man hang with the
guys there's some cool music home with
some rap videos and and I'm getting a
money fade and then uh and then it just
started going back a little bit I said
what the [ __ ] man we saved 80 bucks a
month and
just got a buzzer yeah and every dad
will shave it I get a buzz every morning
and uh and it's [ __ ] so comfortable
it is alright the only thing that sucks
now is I said I got a new house I told
Jimmy and I share a bathroom with my
wife now so now it's like oh yeah you're
getting the [ __ ] [ __ ] on the feed you
say like that but yes I have a potty
mouth like me in it and then when you
step on that it goes through the house
and what oh [ __ ] me well sorry
are you HOT are you warm I can see you
sweating a little [ __ ] sue anyone we
don't know fired up I get I get nuts
yeah that's what I woke up a double shot
and I did some push-ups cuz I usually
try to get his sweat out before I come
do the show with Jimmy and this was too
early I had to get here early right so
after my espresso I got to the [ __ ]
train I came in here and I was still a
little tired believe it or not so I had
a 5-hour extra strength 5-hour energy
yeah awesome I'm about to do [ __ ]
cartwheels right yeah you're all fired
up now you got some of those tissues
tissues arm does have any [ __ ] paper
towels when you uh we get a bounty
[ __ ] old [ __ ] no [ __ ] when you say
we're fading yes and you get all into
you yeah just at did you ever get like a
hard-on you know just by accident has
that ever happened like I was fighting
yes you get an erection whatever [ __ ]
cuz that's losses problem is that
everybody pops boners - guys I get
really close to somebody else I'm not
that's funny that's funny you said that
because no because you know like I was
bugging Jimmy you guys look at that I
tell you I'm gonna go back to our
[ __ ] little [ __ ] shitty studio I
see unfiltered and I'm gonna start
demanding some [ __ ] you guys are good
Adrienne's are old bounty [ __ ] Adrienne
you're awesome yeah ah the [ __ ] was I
doing it was a some owners back to the
[ __ ] yeah no no I used to bug Jimmy cuz
you know true Brazilian Jujitsu is made
for like the weaker guy I'm not
attacking you there Jimmy no you're
right it's made for the smaller guy
didn't train yourself against a bigger a
weaker it was a good fine art yeah so I
had the pickle
Machel are right for Jim Norton to get
good at Brazilian Jujitsu sure because
he could if not take out a bigger guy
get defend themself well then get his
you don't think it's right whistle WIP
bugging Jimmy everyday Lucian in come on
never shine that flashlight in his eyes
that strobing is if it stops anybody and
he could defend himself so with
Brazilian Jujitsu yeah I want to take it
but Matt a lot that was in New York I'd
be in his place three times which is
hard to get online have you done any of
it ever and I just we karate sounds when
I feel threatened what it had what kind
of sounds oh wow I backed I I think he's
confident for summary but then that
takes us away from the point which was
Oh
boners I'll get to that I know you are I
was telling Jimmy I go Jimmy I go come
on man you'd love it you'd love [ __ ]
Jiu Jitsu and then one day he goes now I
I don't want to do it you know I'm
afraid I'll come asked him since to do
anything yeah and I was so I was bugging
him I don't know maybe just said it so
I'd stop bugging him and he said oh no I
want to try it like out name some places
for you I did but when we went to the
fight in Vegas we went to the Chael
Sonnen Anderson Silva rematch in Vegas
yeah yeah anyway do it Sam yes I said
yes I did um but I remember and it's
goes to Voss's point that we went to the
weigh-in and one of the guys I don't
remember which fighter it was but he had
a hard-on at the weigh-in are you sure
down Sam I don't yeah so give himself up
when we were looking at this guy's
I noticed I noticed but you would have
noticed right [ __ ] noticed I wouldn't I
would have got front row yeah now look
now with all right guys first guy right
look a you tell me that is not it's not
a [ __ ] get him that's that that's not
good that's not he's right he's excited
son of Harlem he's excited he's ready to
fight he's gonna get a boner
not everyone I could just be your
[ __ ] helmet you dicks flopped out a
certain way I don't know I don't know me
he might have big balls that looks like
me you buy me a mighty undies in fact
I never Oh god bless him
yeah yes yeah yes sir so with these guys
are all [ __ ] ripped man get them
they're all [ __ ] ripped we have very
good Jim yeah [ __ ] athletes they're
about to fight in a [ __ ] cage yeah
holy [ __ ] I like the tattoos on this one
what are you doing right like your ass
your guy you watch for the aesthetics is
that a tattoo they have a nice day of
nice work you know a forces problem is
with MMA's yeah just Nighy doesn't know
it they're not cute enough you like the
in karate they're all so much cuter
right no MMA guys are [ __ ] I'm amazed
when I look at them I'll [ __ ] rip
those [ __ ] they look like [ __ ]
rappers I could fight the rappers are
also handsome though the ripped oh I see
you like their bodies who doesn't are
you a hip-hop fan Matt Serra yes
do you like because their body when I
trained I remember I put it on no no
when I trained it at my school I put in
some rap strength training in Pandora
put that [ __ ] in yeah oh you leastly
want to punch your mother but you
probably listen at all you don't listen
to new rap do you I I believe it or not
I do I put that on chance the rapper no
now you're throwing some curveballs at
me now you're a younger guy oh you 3333
yeah Wow the shoulders all right 33 not
only hitting are you live in a lottery
dude I am married yeah why marry now
we've been married for somewhere I know
that's not good yeah between they even
have an answer think three four years
I'd probably four year three or four
years I don't know what Adrian knows
what the [ __ ] you've been a dreamer you
best man or something how do you know he
wasn't even there by he's the he's the
producer yeah it's disinformation I've
been I've been with Matt he said I'll
text Jess I've been with my wife for
like 11 years I mean about forever so
here's our 20s yeah I mean oh yeah and
no kids no kids no you plan on get any
of them yeah yeah we're going to yes
right good yeah you know man
Wow Sam James only has been hard on the
marriage children oh my what is your
impotence do you want your kids hair to
look like
Menem nice hair or like yours like
colored people
you know you hadn't added in the color
people famous better shot at me but yet
to just take a shot at all black people
no you said like colored people what are
you saying you you said I'm all I'm
stuck in my way sorry I didn't mean a
race I'm not a racist you're right
you're Jewish no no I'm not sure my guys
Antonio is Jorge type of dog sorry I'm
not you too Tyson yeah though nobody
also bite but for the record Mike Tyson
also referred to me as a black
[ __ ]
so don't open just expand I'm not listen
I can knock you look at me I've no hair
no I guess I'm getting there no but what
do we what am I looking at now as you
mmm Kazama Jewish any to MMA fighters or
yeah great question I won tonight do you
guys you guys have Jews and colors in
MMA now it was then I would start
following them right there are I don't
you fighter lose your hair come from
though what is your background
I don't know Dave what is it David we
everybody in my family is white with my
own odds not on my mom's side you said
no one run a couple of my uncle's have
curly hair like me they had a frozen
like the sixties and seventies a curly
afro that's a [ __ ] it's it's gross oh
it's not gross
I think it's unique thank you I'll get
you no thank you it adds character yeah
no you can people I enjoy a [ __ ]
answer to it's true there's no answer
you yes the day they let Jewish people
for change I don't watch it you know I'm
like I'm not saying I don't know what
anybody did any of them are I'm sure
there's some of them visually I don't
really know really the cut I don't
really look into that too much unless
the guy walked into the [ __ ] fight
with a yarmulke on or something I don't
know what the what we look cool that
I've Jewish émigrés 20 you're 33 I'm 33
how that decision makes you grow old
fast
you because she's my Giri I just say it
I don't know I can't yeah why would you
revisit the joke like way minutes later
lady business is the first time I wish I
was reading attacks I can get back there
uh these are all Jewish fighters Emily
Kagan
Rory singer Oh Meola hi Rory singer I
know Rory he doesn't he sell [ __ ]
jewelry in Philly
he didn't say Oh Steven singer play on
singers you already hey listen it's
[ __ ] funny I'm done Rory singer looks
like a if I could don't do it the
Ultimate Fighter back in today boss what
do you think of Rory's body well let me
see if yeah let me see a flat I'm it's
alright it's not bad it's ready I mean I
want more rip than that yeah right
you're not more ripped in that you know
you looking shape how old are you
Yeah right you're not you're not more
wait I'll be 60 in June oh [ __ ] you're a
couple years of the logo look at that
body you sure it all your little friends
with that around your neck you look like
a [ __ ] shoes [ __ ] superstar with
that bus took his shirt off
I let me tell you something if you pound
on shape you doing you choosing what's
that you juicing steroids you gonna gas
yeah you're saving yourself drugs you
got great what happened you have a
problem yeah crack freebase really oh
yeah it was good [ __ ] man oh hello you
wanna look to crack why was I was a drug
addict I mean I started getting high
when I was you know 15 16 on with it
okay
my bottom uh has been [ __ ] by other
neither the Sun boys you know smoking
free Bay yeah so that's probably why you
know now you never had you never like
had they give a guy oral for drugs did
you I did it for fun
yeah for a Flintstones chewable no I
know I mean listen make coach about it
but you know I mean I've done so far but
if you give you given all kidding aside
I'll [ __ ] punch through your hats
joking you are but it's a serious issue
I feel Furio his head off his head oh
yeah yeah being your head okay in your
mouth anther lifted eyes down we'll talk
about you knocking people on
life-changing [ __ ] addiction listen
to me little Stretch Armstrong good why
don't you set sixteen do they right now
they don't [ __ ] take HGH I [ __ ]
love you growth hormone and steroid at
60 everybody was 60 and written English
yeah so wait no when did you a marriage
fall apart which was twice oh you don't
miss your second Swansea greats yeah the
first one can I have a couple kids that
fall to [ __ ] because of your addiction
no she never saw me high I was clean
when I got mad oh how long did that go
for your first marriage five years well
that's not that this one's it going on
twelve oh five years and that's when you
have your first two kids from you yeah I
didn't you only my first five years to
your freshman yes okay yeah you find
what happened around the five year mark
just like all [ __ ]
now yeah she got married young yeah what
good fun I stayed for mother you kids
listen she lived right by me she should
babysit our kid you know you know we go
over her house I mean she root in North
Carolina now I was good friends with her
before you cheating no no never no no
I'm not that kind of person
okay oh I'm so sorry I didn't mean to
stop on your moral high ground
yeah the trainer is just in the hall
there's another stuff no so I I say go
you didn't work out you know what I mean
so I stayed good friends I we were
separated for five years as I was
showing her insurance
and don't we just moved on but we always
stay here we have kids you're more you
[ __ ] up as a married guy example
relate to this other guy what he's
married but now if it go if what if did
you tell yourself I'm like if I could
have this marriage I'm not I'm not going
I'm never going back in don't know you
say I'm gay I'll do it again when I meet
my psyche I just love my life now you
play by ear I mean I was single for 11
years between marriage 10 years and you
know Yvonne Lee and as comics you know
you get listen I was getting pushed on a
road like it was [ __ ] you know it
just helped me a [ __ ] which got so much
[ __ ] he actually brought me into the
fold and everybody would [ __ ] him and
then he have to I'm like almost like
he's like he's ugly friend you guys
gettin you guys get a lot of groupies
with the comedy all rich would just go
rich rich to make girls go in the closet
watch me jerk off is that right you're
the best
he's the best he would tell them to like
oh yeah watch him jerk off in the closet
so we get Malone in his car let's sit in
the backseat and watch he [ __ ] around
you see husband Sarah he was a trooper
so I did you what was the strategy
because a lot of comedians complain
about the lack of groupies well now what
it's [ __ ] 2016 different ones in the
80s good all the aides pushy at you back
then you know I got vote I mean I got
blown in a coatroom once you after my
show you know what I mean yeah sure she
kept that job you know horrible after a
while you're single on your life yeah
they but I just met my wife who's a
comic - yeah and it just happened you
know you you don't question the comic
also yeah you don't plant a brilliant
and you don't plan it it's just happy I
guess it just happens
cuz I think you're right like if you if
you're some have your marriage fell
apart you would get married again I mean
that's what you tell yourself I'm right
I mean listen I'm gonna it's a bit
depends on the day you get me but right
now I'm gonna you know sometimes I'm
with Jimmy and I'll [ __ ] vent on air
about certain [ __ ] but uh you know being
a married guy and especially with kids
see that's a different situation for you
Sam because I don't they don't hold the
same kind of power and I got a great
thing going on three
beautiful kids my wife's awesome but
they do get to talk to you a certain way
that they would never talk to you if you
didn't have children with them I mean
that's how I feel like in other words
how about this oh how about my wife's
[ __ ] my wife is really awesome
awesome anybody needs oh she's so the
nicest person is but let me tell you
something this times when I'm fighting
with her and I'm just like yo there's
not a single person on the planet that
could talk to me like that when I'm up
being a tough guy I'm saying there's
gonna be repercussions someone's either
getting [ __ ] up not a girl I mean
obviously but just you can't or if it's
if it's a girlfriend she's [ __ ]
kicked to the curb I mean it's just not
happening right just not [ __ ]
happening but like I said I'm in a good
situation
no I might bring that back my wife says
marriage my wife Nancy ended a bed every
night giving me a lecture of what I did
wrong that day oh you know I mean like I
was your wife now yeah I mean she's I
mean look I think Oh second time I guess
is the charm the same business so we're
around you know you know I was a crack
addict piece of [ __ ] back in it you know
now my like you're not a crack addict is
right my life now it's like Lane and
Bella my wife eating a protein bar which
is a pretty big [ __ ] change protein
oh yeah exactly that's not enough for
her you know she'll come in and go um
fold the laundry and I also mean the
Lord we're so bad yeah I mean so it's
just you know you have a house little
things like how come you didn't empty
the [ __ ] dishwasher cuz I didn't care
about it yeah you know that's typical
stuff no stuff turns into fights with us
yeah and why don't you one she's empty
the dishwasher bro why really yeah
really yeah why don't you just put that
in the garbage the garbage is right
there why do you leave it right damaged
yeah look at that
why got it difficult about it because I
have things going on you do yeah nothing
we got a new CD on iTunes if you
pre-ordered which boss five that's right
my new one here have one what is this CD
holiday one anyway what is this a
frisbee
oh look at this there you are you want
to use this rich if you feel like using
the mic you can bet you're doing like a
firm very rigid it's up to you it's work
but the mic if you want it you can shut
the microphone yeah you can talk into it
if you are shameless and I'm not
attacked on me yeah I'm not attacking
your haircut from 1991 but you can never
say anything about Sam again if I
[ __ ] view post this yeah but mine
looks like Roger Daltrey no they don't
haircut isn't Arab fine bulb this is
coming to America this is the [ __ ]
soul wall from [ __ ] ah you would
leave a stain on any couch you put your
head back that's right oh my gosh face
into a blind panic nomination my big one
[ __ ] very funny prank did bad things to
Voss his teeth I went to the dentist
with him remember when we did that oh
yeah and he had to he had to get you
know he is it's either fakie to get him
sewed on implants but like they
literally had to had to pull his gums
back pack it in with cadaver bones
because his teeth are these just little
tiny like it looks like like like he's
been possessed like there's just little
sharp stars and dummy actually but he's
on when they put uh yeah uh implants yes
is $35,000 worth the [ __ ] teeth way
wow she's a lot of [ __ ] money yeah
and he actually took his fingers he said
that here I grabbed it across his teeth
that's okay he paid for me could touch
it that's true
yeah thank you for a play-by-play I
didn't need to do that and you and how
long were you addicted to the crack two
weeks oh that's no three years three
years three and then one day you said
fog I said I might either die or go to
jail
so I said I got to get clean or else all
up I wish I could help you with that
decision yeah one of the new is a fine
option advertising this AC I'm here no
matter what's going on in your life
and all the negative and all the
meanness I'm still here for you so
whatever you hear because we're on the
radio you need to plug